[Music]
black people watching this show right
now and they're wondering what what it's
like to come to a live taping of our
show and so we've prepared a very short
video to show you exactly what it takes
to be in the conan audience what it
takes to be an audience member okay
first you really need to wake up
if you oversleep that's fine the show
doesn't tape until late in the day but
you really do need to at least wake up
good
now breakfast is important so make sure
that you yes a happy burrito is exactly
what we were going to suggest do you
know what you're wearing to the show no
problem do you have gum perfect you're
ready for the next step getting to the
studio is as easy as one two three
three-and-a-half four now you're ready
to join the line of people in the
parking garage here you get to show off
your standing skills but don't get too
comfortable because soon it's time to
walk to a new location where you get to
stand again now it's time to walk almost
half a mile to get to the studio don't
talk to anyone you'll need all your
energy to complete the trip finally
you're at the show now have a seat and
wait in just a few short hours the show
will begin and we'll need you to be
ready because you are the audience
[Music]
they seem to like it too much
you didn't have to like that piece of
that much like it you